je suis ramené à sa bonne je suis
tunisienne elle m'a dit je suis un
oiseau qui est né dans la cage ou pense
que voler est une maladie c'était ça
[Musique]
c'était il ya dix ans un air de révolte
s'empare du monde arabe dans la rue les
dégage résonne aux oreilles des régimes
autoritaires
en première ligne la jeunesse elle qui a
porté la révolution se demande parfois
ce qu'il reste à célébrer aujourd'hui
dans cette vidéo cap sur la tunisie aux
côtés de ranelagh et de zyed ses 11 989
donc deux ans après l'installation du
système de baladi donc je connaissais
que benali jusqu'à l'âge de 21 ans qui
est ce qui est ce qui n'est pas normal
donc voilà j'ai grandi avec la dictature
il n'y a pas de liberté d'expression et
à les photos du parti et n'importe où
même le sentiment de nationalisme et
n'avait pu eux-mêmes mais même à voir le
drapeau c'était une sorte de l'adhérence
à haut régime est apparu comme un parti
politique de ben ali avait pas le 17
décembre 2010 un jeune vendeur ambulant
se voit confisquer sa marchandise par la
police
vous connaissez son mohamed bouazizi
s'immole devant la préfecture de sidi
bouzid le printemps arabe commence
[Musique]
un jeu qui se suicident à cause de
l'injustice n'était pas une première en
tunisie
voilà c'était un système injuste et tout
le monde le sait j'étais à tunis à
l'époque et ailleurs il ya des vidéos
commencent à voir sur facebook il ya les
gens qui commencent à parler d'une
révolution envoyer des vidéos circulé
sur facebook que sur les réseaux sociaux
ces vidéos qui sont censurés par le
système
les dunes rappelle bien que une fois
j'ai partagé une de vidéos
le lendemain j'ai rencontré une amie qui
m'a dit mais non rania tu t'étais follow
quoi tu partages tu partages ce genre de
chose de ta pas peur je pense que
j'avais quand même peur mais j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi à 21 et non on ne
réfléchit pas beaucoup aux conséquences
il y avait un mot on disait de bagages à
l'époque au système donc tout le monde
fasse taire comme un hashtag dégage tout
le monde dégage comme ça au régime à la
corruption à belles années
et le 14 janvier c'était à tunis et ma
mère voulait pas absolument aucune sorte
y avait mon père c'était disait laissez
le partir parce que c'est une journée
historique il senti que c'était quelque
chose c'est en lien était en train
d'écrire d'écrire l'histoire
c'était univers il faisait très froid
dont donc ses légions et je me rappelle
bien des visages ça se voyait le la
pauvreté la misère ça se voyait sur sur
les traits des jours en arrivant là bas
j'ai rencontré des gens que je
connaissais
j'ai vu mes preuves par exemple vous
savez on n'a jamais parlé politique
c'était quelque chose qui est
exceptionnel parce que on voyait ces
gens là on salit pas on est tous
ensemble en fait devant le mystère
c'était le symbole d'une la dictature
symbole du pouvoir et on disait dégage
c'était un moment historique c'était un
moment exceptionnel et le soir on en
tant que co ben ali était parti
[Musique]
les premiers jours qui ont succédé la le
14 janvier 2011
c'est une journée magnifique d'utiliser
un compte était très soudé la révolution
nous a rapprochés de la dynamique des
jeunes qui voulaient vraiment faire des
choses et là on voit que ce qu'on a fait
ces soulèvements là ce que cette
protestation cette révolution nous a
amenés à faire fuir le dictateur on
lâche à fait à cette époque je voulais
que des choses positives bien sûr la
liberté ne peut être que quelque chose
de positif
la liberté d'expression et le droit à
sprinter voir des corps ont pu s'enfuir
dont des avions donc c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire dans la première
élection enfin j'étais observateurs pour
les élections et toutes mes amis ils ont
participé à l'observation parce qu'on
croyait pas qu'on peut voter librement
on va être sans craindre un rien
bon allez partir choisir qui on veut on
vote et notre vote il va être pris en
considération
j'ai passé 24 heures au bureau de vote
pour surveiller
depuis c'est une journée incroyable
[Musique]
quel chemin encore à parcourir
bon j'aurais bien aimé être plus
optimiste dix ans après la révolution de
la scène politique aujourd'hui il manque
encore de maturité je pense qu'il ya un
peu d'amateurisme
ils n'ont ils n'ont toujours pas compris
en fait le citoyen tunisien et ses
ambitions et ce qu'il en est ce qu'il
veut vraiment faim j'ai l'impression que
la lune
une partie du site et n'a pas beaucoup
changé
on a encore en voit encore la corruption
des gens corrompus
si on regarde les échanges à l'assemblée
ccc un sketch 25e place de théâtre sens
a fait et ça fait ça fait mal au coeur
parce que après tout on se dit mais
attend mais nous on a on a fait on a
failli mourir pour pouvoir pour en
arriver là
et êtes-vous aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous faites c'est pas normal c'est
anormal
[Musique]
m